[Music]
hello everyone thank you all for coming
and let's get started so I'm Matthew and
today my colleagues and I will be
talking about how we are making the
Android runtime also known as art faster
in Android Q we will also be showing you
some both some internal knowledge about
art as well as some best practices such
as using the report fully drawn API as
well as when to use object pooling and
now a recap about how art works so art
is the software layer in between the
Android operating system and the
applications it provides an execution
environment
for running both Kotlin and Java
language applications on Android to do
this art does two things it processes
Dex files the internal format of Android
applications through a hybrid model
consisting of interpretation
just-in-time compilation and profile
based ahead of time compilation art also
manages memory by having automatic
reclamation through a concurrent
compacting garbage collector that we
introduced in Android Oreo so an update
on profiles in the cloud so art has had
profiles that contain information about
application usage on Android since
nougat and until recently these profiles
are only local to the device these
profiles are collected by the distant
time compiler and are saved to device
storage during application execution and
later are used to optimize the
application since these were only
locally stored on the device until
recently this meant that applications
have to run a while have their profile
saved and then we have to optimize the
application when the phone was charging
or when the device was charging in the
background to address this we introduced
a new service called profiles in the
cloud
which was announced last year at Google
i/o and today we're gonna be providing
some more updates about how that's going
so before we dip dive into profiles in
the cloud let's take a closer look at
what's inside of a profile profiles
contain detailed information about
application usage including what methods
are run and what classes are loaded
during bolts startup and during a steady
state of the application usage this
enables art to compile the methods that
are the most important to machine code
as well as optimize the application for
startup by prioritizing code that is run
during startup for performance profiles
in the cloud enabled downloading the
profile alongside the application during
installation and then optimizing the
application during installation this
means that the users get the performance
directly after installation and no
longer have to wait for the application
to get optimized when the device is
charging in the background so here we've
observed speed ups of around 15% faster
applications start up directly after
installation so now let's dive into how
the whole profile and the cloud process
works so the main idea here is that
applications usually have commonly
shared code paths between a multitude of
users and devices so this means that
most users are gonna have generally the
same use case for startup and app the
application usage in general so what we
want to do with profiles in the cloud is
have the initial users bootstrap
performance for the rest of the users
and this is often a takes advantage or
benefits from the fact that developers
roll out the applications incrementally
with alpha beta channels so once an
application is installed the profiles
are uploaded to play and are aggregated
into what we call a common core profile
for the application and in future
installs this common core profile is
downloaded alongside the application and
used optimize the application during
installation
this improves both the steady-state
performance as well as the startup I'd
like to note that Android P also has API
support that non play devices can
leverage as for numbers as you can see
here YouTube has a large startup
improvement around 18% from profiles in
the cloud and other applications also
have substantial improvement this is
field data of Google applications
collected from pixel devices and one of
the best parts of all this is that
developers and users get the benefits
for free developers don't have to write
a single line of code to enable the
profiles for their applications and
users don't have to take any action to
get the benefits and right now around 80
percent of installations on devices with
Google Play services use profiles in the
cloud another interesting observation is
that the profiles in the cloud seems to
show that only around 20% of application
code is commonly used this could
indicate that there are opportunities to
reduce code size by removing unused code
in applications and now let's go to app
startup we have done some improvements
in queue and I'll be going over some of
those in Android q we have done three
major new improvements we've improved
the application images originally
introduced in Android nougat to provide
a larger startup improvement we have
added free forking of application
processes to accelerate process creation
on Android and we have added a new
generational garbage collector so
starting with application images recall
that application images as you see other
year's i/o talks are actually C realized
heap snapshots
containing the classes that are the most
commonly used during startup of an
application so this optimizes the
performance by shifting the work of
loading those classes from happening
during startup to happening ahead of
time in the art ahead of time compile
so the application image is generated by
the compiler taking both the application
apk and the profile as inputs and then
using the profile to know specifically
what classes are loaded during startup
and including only these in the
application images this is done during
installation if there is a profile from
the cloud presence otherwise it's
normally done in the background when the
device is charging so how have we
improved application images in Android
queue well we recently observed that
string interning cause specifically by
using string literals in application
startup was taking a large amount of
time so we added an optimization to
include the string literals that are
commonly used during startup for the
application inside of the application
image this is accomplished by leveraging
the profile to know specifically what
methods are executed during startup so
as you can see here there's around a 2.5
percent improvement on some applications
and this is a selection of first party
applications running on a pixel to excel
and now let me hand it off to Chris for
pre forking application processes Thank
You Matthew
hello everyone my name is Chris and I am
here to talk about some of the changes
we have made to the zygote in Android
queue to help improve a application
starter performance for those of you
unfamiliar with the zygote this is the
process in Android that all applications
are spawned from this design allows us
to take several application several
steps that are common to all Android
applications and perform them before the
applications are launched
unfortunately in previous versions of
Android there were still several
application agnostic steps that had to
be performed after the application was
launched
these include such things as process
spawning thread creation driver loading
and resource cleanup in android q we're
introducing the unspecialized app
process pool unspecial ID app and
specialized app processes are created
and performed these application agnostic
steps off the critical path of
application startup this produces an
average speed up of approximately five
milliseconds for most applications on a
pixel to device but more importantly it
forms a foundation for further
improvements to applications startup so
now let's take a look at some of the
changes we've made to the early stages
of app startup to make it faster on the
Left we can see the launching process
from previous versions of Android it
involves three communicating processes
one of which must be created during this
critical launch window it also involves
inter process communication or IPC and
this requires the zygote to wake up
block unblock and send a message to the
system server all of these steps take
resources away from the operating system
and the application that the users are
trying to launch on the right we can see
the new much simpler app launch process
in android q the zygote has been
completely removed from this critical
path the new also the new process that
will become the application already
exists in the system and has performed
these application agnostic steps already
by removing the zygote we also eliminate
an entire inter-process communication
round and this means that the new
application can talk directly to the
system server and not wake up the zygote
and consume system resources
in a couple slides I'm gonna be talk
about some of the metric and
investigation we've worked work we've
done in Android queue to help improve
applications startup performance but I
wanted to briefly mention the metrics
that is directly impacted by these
changes which is time to first slice
time to first slice as a measure of how
quickly we can begin running application
specific code and as we can see in this
graph there is a fairly uniform
improvement again of approximately five
milliseconds to the time to first slice
metric for these seven apps on a pixel
to device however this is just the
beginning for the speed ups and
improvements we can see from the using
unspecialized app processes follow-up
work that is currently in testing shows
an additional speed-up on the order of
ten of tens of milliseconds the best
news for users and developers alike is
that all applications will see these
improvements without requiring any
changes to their application or they way
that they use their advice so now I'm
going to talk briefly about the
measurement work that we've been doing
an Android q when performance tuning
software's complicated as an operating
system it's very important to get a deep
understanding of what is happening when
it's happening and how long it is taking
to this end we have spent a lot of time
looking at traces and log files over the
last couple months we've also developed
several new tools for extracting
actionable and useful insights from this
large corpus of data one of these tools
is publicly available to you and that's
the start up analyzer script this script
will extract detailed information about
startup events from trace files
including start-up duration scheduling
status and binder transactions one of
the most important questions that this
work made us ask ourself is when does
application startup end well there are
many criteria that we can use to that
might signal when startup is finished
including when the first frame of the
user interface is drawn and this is
certainly a useful definition it's one
we can use to optimize
moments but it doesn't tell us when the
user perceives the application to be
usable which is what we consider to be
the gold standard for applications start
up endpoint unfortunately we don't have
a way to automatically detect when this
happens we do however have an API call
the developers can use to tell us when
you think it happens this makes it
easier for us to identify the
application startup process for
individual apps and make sure that we
optimize the things that are important
to your app so if you would like to help
us speed up the performance of your
application I highly recommend that you
use this report fully draw an API call
so thank you for your time and at this
point I'm gonna hand the state over to
Roland for a discussion of the garbage
collection work that we've done in queue
thank you Chris hi everyone my name is
Hollow and I'm going to present the
improvements we've made in our cabbage
collector for Android cute another word
queue we've improved our concurrent copy
garbage collector in two ways first by
adding support for generational garbage
collection which makes GC cheaper
overall and second by using a two-phase
collection strategy which makes garbage
collection more precise and able to
reclaim more objects during the
development of Android queue we've also
reevaluated the benefits of object
pooling versus standard allocation in
arts in the last section of this talk
would share with you our findings and
new recommendation regarding object
pooling
but for now let's have a look at garbage
collection generational garbage
collection in android 800 we introduced
the concurrent covering garbage
collector or CC collector in arts this
year we added support for generational
collection to this collector in anyway
queue the CC collector alternates Fulop
collections and young generation
collections these young generation
collections only process a fraction of
the heap they are cheaper and almost as
effective as full hip collections before
look at generation collection let's have
a look at look at how the concurrent
copying garbage collector works the
garbage collector in arts is a
concurrent copying one it is concurrent
because it runs at the same time and an
app's thread and it does not require a
long stop the world pause this work
thanks to a cooperation between the GC
and the apps code all accesses to object
references are instrumented in the
runtime with what we call read barriers
and they ensure that the app does not
see a stale object the GC is also said
to be copying because it moves live
objects in memory by making a copy of
them and reclaiming the space that held
the original objects including the data
objects this copying strategy means that
the GC is compacting the heap and
preventing fragmentation let's see how
this works
copying collector traditionally splits
the managed heap into spaces a from
space which contains the object
currently allocated and used and a to
space to each live objects a move during
garbage collection during a GC cycle the
collector traces the heat it follows
route references to manage objects for
instance from its thread stack and marks
all objects reachable from these routes
to compute the set of live objects they
are reachable objects in dark red in
this illustration are the ones which are
not visited by the collector reachable
objects are copied to the to space as
they are being marked by the GC
and likewise all other reachable objects
living in the front spacer could be to
the to space they're being marked thus
compacting the heat and the other the
collection the object that haven't been
moved are the dead ones and because they
are not reachable and the GC can then
reclaim the memory used by the from
space finally the front space and the to
space are swapped and new locations
happen in the new from space
so that's heap compaction in a nutshell
let's see how this works in arts so for
practical reasons
RCC collector does not use two semi
spaces for a region space composed of
256 kilobyte regions as an app's memory
needs grow over time new regions are
located to Co spec to create space for
new objects I think the previous example
we're highlighting unreachable objects
in dark red color at the beginning of a
cheesy cycle the garbage collector max
decision for each region in use the
first option is to evacuate a region
which means moving all live objects out
of it and reclaim the memory backing the
region at the end of the cycle this
makes sense if there's a good proportion
of data objects in this region because
evacuating it means it will have compact
the heap and fit some physical memory
but if most of the allocated object in
these regions are actually alive there
will be little benefits to evacuated and
maybe some costs because of the object
copies in that case did you see my
decide to keep the region as is and we
call that an an evacuated region in dark
green in this diagram until Android cue
the decision to evacuate a region or not
was based on information from a previous
duty cycle which is not optimal later
and is thought my colleague Lokesh will
talk more about this
tracing and marking works similarly to
the priests example but instead of
copying our mercury object to a fixed -
space area they are copied to a freshly
allocated region called an evacuation
region
if this region speeds up during garbage
collection another region is allocated
and so on and so the whole heap has been
traced and the energy GC cycle the to
space is the union of all the evacuation
regions and the region that had been
allocated for new object allocations
evacuated regions eventually are
reclaimed and their memory the pages are
returned to the system now that we've
seen how arts concurrent collector works
let's see at let's have a look at the
generational version even if the CC
collector does not evacuate all regions
it has to trace all the objects this is
known as a full hip collection but
consider this if the GC what you process
only recently allocated objects it will
in general collect most of them and for
a fraction of the costs of a food heap
collection this is this is what we call
the generational hypothesis in most
cases young objects emerged more likely
to die than old objects art generational
CC collector introducing the concept of
young generation collection only tracing
recently allocated regions these are
called minor collections are supposed to
fool hip collections with a called major
collections there's a GC heuristics
which tries to use minor collection
firsts and it runs major collections if
needed in a young generation collection
we handle newly allocated ijen specially
these regions are the ones which have
been allocated in the previous GC cycle
and the objects are much more likely to
be unreachable
therefore these regions are the only one
evacuated during a minor collection and
they're also the only regions which are
being traced during a minor collection
all generation objects have survived at
least one collection and they are more
likely to be still alive so they're not
traced
during a minor collection overall this
results in a much faster GC cycle
by tracing young generation regions from
the roots and also in other to any trace
objects in the young generation we need
to determine the reach ability to do so
we need to track references from the
roots to the young object as we did in
the full hippo actions but we also need
to trace references from old object to
young objects because the old objects
are not race we track such young young
to the old Auto young object references
using a remember sets mechanism which
keeps tracks of references object whose
field i've been modified since the last
GC cycle
minor collection yeah by tracing the
young generations from the roots and
remember sets we can identify live young
objects and copy them out of the region
without the need to trade the whole heap
and this is the main benefit of minor
collections minor collection do not
process all generation object that could
have been reclaimed in the food
collection we call that floating garbage
they will eventually be collected during
the next full hip collection let's now
see the impact of generation CC on our
own arts performance to assess the
impact of generational CC collection on
arts we've measured the average CPU time
spent in the garbage collector thread on
some GC internship benchmarks we use the
edge to benchmark from the deck above
sweets which is an in-memory database
benchmark as well as our internal
village seeds benchmark because both are
good examples of allocation and garbage
collection workloads on average the
generational CC collector is 38% faster
on h2 and 33% faster on sheets while
compared with the non generational
garbage collector that we shipped in
under 8 P
now this is the direct results of a
younger generation collection being
cheaper in terms of CPU time so to put
it in a nutshell using short of objects
is now cheaper and also as a consequence
of these improvements we expect that
because we're spending less time in the
garbage collector this will benefits the
device battery life improvements in
garbage collection often I lights
shredders between CPU and RAM usage
generational garbage collector may keep
some objects a bit longer in order to
speed up the overall GC execution to
talk more about these how we can improve
these trade-offs and heap compaction I'm
handing it over to Lokesh
[Applause]
hi everyone I hope you still have some
stamina left for more technical stuff so
let's start off with talking a little
bit more about how hip compaction works
in CeCe
so as you can imagine the more live
objects there are in a compacting region
the lesser memory you would reclaim if
you were to compact it and so it makes
more sense to only for a higher rate of
interest meant to only compact those
regions which have considerable garbage
in them and that's exactly what
concurrent coping collector does we
maintain a Perth Region liveness stat
which indicates how much live data is
there in a particular region and based
on that decide which regions are worth
evacuating and which are not another
interesting fact about the CC algorithm
is that it during a GC cycle it only
goes through all the reachable objects
only once while this is a very useful
fact about any GC algorithm because it
it shows how efficient the algorithm is
let's see how it affects the heap
compaction decisions that we make so
this is a hypothetical timeline of some
Z some apps execution and as you can
imagine during the execution
periodically we need to perform GC
cycles in order to reclaim memory which
is consumed by unreachable objects so
that future object allocations can be
served
and since CC hill Android P was not
generational so all these GC cycles work
on all the reachable objects and
therefore I'm calling them full heap GC
cycles so when we start off with the
first GC cycle by the time we revisit
all the reachable objects we know
precisely which region has how many live
bytes in them and therefore we can
gather the liveness stats that I talked
about in the previous slide as a time
goes by
due to the execution of application
threads the Hume you tation would result
in more of
it's becoming unreachable and
unreachable however by the time the next
DC cycle is executed where you would
actually use the stats that you gathered
in the previous DC cycle those Klieman
stats no longer show you the the
liveness at that point in time this
leads to what Roland earlier described
floating garbage which is the
unreachable objects that the garbage
collector knows about but it cannot
collect them and of course as in the
previous DC cycle by the end of this GC
cycle also since we have gone through
all the live objects we gather the
liveness stats which then are used in
the next CC cycle and this goes and on
this is how decision-making works in
Android people now let's see how
introducing generations into this
affects the the decision-making for
region selection as Roland described
earlier the benefits of generation GC is
that we can reduce the number of full
heap GC cycles by replacing them with
more frequent young collections which
are much more light weighted as they
only work on young objects young
reachable objects and therefore what
this leads to is that you would have
lesser G full heap GC cycles but also
that the time lag between two full heap
GC cycles would increase and so given
that when we start execution the first
GC cycle being full heap DC cycle we
compute the liveness stats as I
described in the previous case however
every time when we perform young
collection we cannot update these stats
because we only go through young objects
and since we don't go through all the
reachable objects it's not possible to
you know update the liveness stats and
by the time we reach the next full heap
GC cycle where we actually use the
lioness stats they become much more
stale than what it would have happened
in case of Android B or earlier and
therefore it leads to larger amount of
flow
in garbage and this goes on on and on
given the limited availability of memory
on you know for mobile devices it makes
sense to ensure that this floating
garbage is minimally and and the cause
of that we identified is clear that the
outer outdated liveness stats is what is
hurting us so we fix the issue by
improving the heap compaction by
replacing the full heap GC cycle with
another algorithm which you which is
two-faced where the first phase would
trace all the life reachable objects and
compute the liveness stats and then the
second phase based on these up-to-date
liveness stats figures out feed region
which regions deserve to be compacted
and then performs compaction this way
very both the benefits of generations GC
by ensuring that young collection
remains as it is as well as we fix the
problem of outdated lamina stats let's
see using the same example that rollin
was earlier using how this new algorithm
works so let's for let's assume that our
evacuation criteria criteria for any
region is that if it has less than three
live objects in it then it deserves to
be compacted so in this example as you
can see that all the four regions which
are in use they have less than three
live objects in them so by the time we
finish the first phase which goes
through all the reachable objects we
have determined that all the four
regions have the liveness stats less
than three objects and therefore they
deserve to be evacuated and by the time
we finish our fully DC cycle we managed
to move all of them into a single region
thereby reclaiming all the four
previously used regions back coming to
what should it lead to the in in terms
of improvement the direct improvement of
this change is that after every full
heap GC cycle we should be
collecting more free bytes BRAC back
from the garbage collector and to
measure that we use the same set of
applications and benchmark that Roland
is earlier described and as you can see
that 4-h to the average freed bytes
improved by more than one hundred and
seventy eight percent whereas four
sheets it improved by sixty eight
percent that's pretty good in terms of
impact of all the both the DC
improvements that Roland and I talked
about on the overall improvement on the
benchmark score we again ran some
benchmarks and we observed that 4-h to
the the spore improved by more than 15%
for both arm and I'm 64 whereas four
sheets is improved by more than 5%
all right enough dragging about
improvements in you let me touch about
touch a different operator let's talk
about object allocation and object
pooling before I conclude I'm sure many
of you must have experienced this you
start writing an app and with standard
object allocation you know simple way
using new operator but as it blows more
and more you start either observing that
there's just too much GC activity going
on or you are spending too much time
allocating new objects or maybe just
somebody said that GC is in effect
inefficient in general and we should
avoid it and then an idea comes to a
mind what if I can cheat the garbage
collector what if instead of giving
those L objects once there once I am
done using them when moving them back to
the garbage collector I could just keep
them around in pools and use them again
and again
isn't it obvious that they should lead
to less garbage and therefore less GC
activity and also that we would be
avoiding the allocation cost given that
in the last few years the garbage
collector Android garbage collector has
him has made several improvements we
thought it's nice time to actually real
open to it and see if it really makes
sense to cool objects or not
so we developed a micro benchmark with
the idea of basically gathering two sets
of metrics one is what is the allocation
overhead for standard allocation versus
acquiring from object pool and second is
that what is the overall CPU overhead of
completing the micro benchmark so
starting with or location overhead as
you can see in this chart that as you
increase the number of fields of the
object that you are pooling the overhead
of pooling and object versus standard
allocation is almost the same
so from allocation overheads point of
view it actually does not make much
sense to pool the objects going to the
CPU overhead this chart shows the best
case for cooling and obviously as
expected the best case was that
basically there is no garbage collector
collection activity at all and therefore
the total CPU overhead of completing the
benchmark in case of pooling was lesser
than standard allocation however there
is a catch the catch is that the best
case loses its practicality as soon as
you go beyond a test program and start
having more and more complicated code by
because you can't be pulling every type
of object in your app you just can't do
that
and therefore we thought we'll make the
benchmark more reasonable and so we
added constant short-lived allocations
in between each iteration to see how it
effects it and as you can see that the
gap between pooling versus standard
allocation has reduced we've been one
step further and we made that a
short-lived allocation proportional to
the size of the object that you are
pulling and now as you can see after a
certain size the overhead of cooling is
more than standard allocation and the
main reason behind this is that even
though by pooling you are reducing the
number of
GC cycles that that's involved but you
are increasing the memory footprint of
your program you have more objects each
time to collect or to process and of
course in addition to higher more
footprints there are many other
disadvantages too like you bring back
all the nightmares of double free and
memory leaks back and also given the
narrow gap between allocation standard
allocation and pooling it may it is very
critical that your implementation of the
pool itself is efficient otherwise
pooling would very quickly become more
more inefficient as compared to standard
allocation so our recommendation is that
please don't use it unless you are
really sure of the benefits and the best
way to be sure of benefits is to measure
if measure when you want to introduce a
new pool to a program see if it benefits
you and then only use it however I still
would say that there are some corner
cases where it could be useful right so
for instance if you are if your app has
a requirement where very large objects
need to be used and then it may make
sense to pull them or if there are
thread-local objects which get allocated
and then dropped on the floor at a very
high frequency then also it may make
sense to pull them but the the peak
point is please measure before deciding
to use them okay so to pre cap we talked
about how we improve the app startup
time by into by using cloud profiles by
introduced improving the app images and
by introducing the app process pools on
the GCS front we already have fast
object allocations since or Android
audio and starting with you we have
introduced the concept of generational
garbage collection and also we improve
the heap compaction using the two phase
algorithm that I talked about and since
it is our endeavour to always keep
improving the arts performance we expect
we will continue to work on these areas
and you can expect to have more
improvements in the future to follow
with that thanks a lot for ending the
presentation I hope it was useful
[Music]
you